justement on va en parler avec notre
envahie spéciale taligne aux gens
bonjour Taline vous êtes prêts à
personne pour France 24 ville récemment
libéré par les Ukrainiens il fait très
froid il fait 3 degrés sur place et les
habitants sont invités à quitter la
ville
oui les autorités ukrainiennes tentent
d'inciter les populations à quitté le
territoire parce que comme vous l'avez
dit il fait très froid trois degrés ce
matin à Carson l'électricité n'est
toujours pas rétablie et tout simplement
parce que les dommages causés par les
troupes russes alors qu'elles ont quitté
la ville et bien ils sont trop
importants pour le moment ce sont que
quelques personnes
âgées et quelques personnes malades qui
se déplacent doucement vers des villes
comme Odessa ou bien plus à l'ouest du
pays des convois humanitaires continuent
d'arriver à Carson rempli de couverture
et de et de vêtements chauds mais cela
ne suffit pas une habitante sur place
nous expliquer que la plupart des
habitations sont munis de chauffage
électrique et non de chauffage au gaz
qui lui fonctionne encore pour le moment
donc la vice-présie la vie se première
ministre ukrainienne elle a appelé
notamment les femmes et les enfants à
s'en aller le gouvernement ukrainien qui
compte prendre en charge les
déplacements que ce soit au niveau du
transport du logement ou de l'accès aux
soins mais le comble en fait c'est que
avec la opérations de Kerson des
centaines d'Ukrainiens ont été séparés
de leurs proches pendant de longs mois
ou bien certains ukrainiens ont aussi pu
quitter la ville donc il n'attendait
plus qu'une chose avec la libération de
Carson c'est de pouvoir retourner sur
place et maintenant et bien les
autorités ukrainiennes c'est l'inverse
qu'elle leur demande parce que on fait
face ici un véritable risque de grande
crise humanitaire le directeur de l'OMS
en Europe a indiqué qu'il allait s'agir
d'une question de survie pour des
millions d'Ukrainiens cet hiver
effectivement l'entendu merci beaucoup